I would say feminists girls that like
are super into only fans club like that
sort of thing and uh whales number one
is Wales do you know why they hate you
like do you do you because I my
perception like the way I feel about it
is that they hate you because you're
saying stuff there's truth to it if
there wasn't truth to what you were
saying they wouldn't hate you they would
just be like oh who cares yeah there's
truth to it and also it makes them
reflect on their own choices so now if
you're talking about how female
promiscuity is not empowering and
they've been promiscuous and they bought
the story that that was somehow
empowering they're listening to you and
they're like we gotta shut her up see
and here's the thing a lot of times you
have this narrative like oh they bought
the story when they're young I don't
really believe that I think a deep down
in an innate level we all know because
what's the first thing that girls call
each other when we're mad you're a hoe
why are you saying that if it's a good
thing I feel like sometimes that's a
cop-out that women use well they'll be
like oh I bought it I'm like did you